اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه
اجمعين اما
بعد سه
الر ان شاء
الله
نكمل
ونواصل ما وقفنا عليه
امس من تفسير سوره
الرعد يقول تعالى في الايه الثامنه
والتاسعه
والعاشره والحدي
عشره الله يعلم ما تحمل كل
انثى وما تغيض الارحام وما تزداد وكل شيء
عنده
مقدار عالم الغيب والشهاده الكبير
المتعال سواء منكم من اسر القول ومن جهر
به ومن هو مستخف بالليل وسارب
بالنهار له معقبات من بين يديه ومن خلفه
يحفظونه من امر
الله ان الله لا يغير ما بقوم حتى يغيروا
ما
بانفسهم واذا ارا د الله بقوم سوء فلا مرد
له وما لهم من دونه من
وال قوله تعالى الله يعلم ما تحمل كل
انثى ما تحمل كل
انثى وما تختص به
الانثى عن الذكر
الرحم يعني في
رحمها الله يعلم ما تح حمل كل انثى من
حمل وما تغيض
الارحام تغيض يعني تنقص او
تنقص الارحام
الرحم ينقص وما في الرحم ينقص كيف
الرحم
ينقص اذا
نقص يعني اذا كان الدم
خرج
في يعني الدوره الشهريه وقت الحمل فان هذا
ينقص من الحمل
كذلك وما
تزداد يعني وما تزداد
الارحام وما
تزداد في
الارحام وبهذا نجمع بين جميع اقوال السلف
والصحابه رحمهم الله تعالى ورضي الله عنهم
في هذه
الايه يعني
تجد
التابعين تابعيهم كذلك تجد الصحابه رضي
الله عنهم وكذلك اهل التفسير
المفسرون تجدهم يختلفون يختلفون في كل شيء
في كل كلمه
لكن الغير متعلم
يظن ان هذا خلاف
تضاد وليس كذلك بل هو
خلاف
تنوع ايش يعني خلاف
تنوع
يعني هذا يقول
شيئا وهذا يقول شيئا وهذا يقول شيئا وهم
في الحقيقه يصفون نفس الشيء لكن باوصاف
مختلفه او مثلا هذا يمثل بشيء على الجنس
ايش يعني يمثل بشيء على الجنس يعني
مثلا لو سالت واحد قلت له ايش الخبز ما هو
الخبز وكان قدامه خبز رغيف خبز فحمله قال
هذا هو الخبز كلامه صحيح ولا مش صحيح
كلامه صحيح لكن هل هذا منتهى
الخبز ما في شيء ثاني في الدنيا كلها توصف
بانه يوصف بانه خبز الا هذا الذي في يده
الجواب لا الجواب في انواع كثيره من الخبز
وخبز كثير هذا نموذج من الخبز صح ولا
لا
فخلاف التنوع كثير
جدا كذلك مثلا يصفون
اوصاف لنفس
الشيء يعني
مثلا يقول الله
تعالى انما يوفى
الصابرون الصابرون من هم الصابرون بيجيك
فلان بقول لك الصابرون الصائمون بيجيك
فلان بقول لك الصابرون عن معصيه الله
وفلان بيجي بيقول لك
الصابرون يعني الصابرون في القتال وهذا
بيجي بيقول الصابرون على الهجره وهذا بيجي
مش قالوا نفس الشيء كل
هذا يعود هذه الاوصاف كلها تعود الى ماذا
الصابرون هذه اوصاف
الصابرين خلاف
التضاد بين الصحابه والتابعين في القران
هذا شيء نادر جدا ولله
الحمد الاول اسمه خلاف تنوع هذا
كثير الثاني اسمه خلاف
تضاد خلاف التضاد هذا ياتي
بتفسير هذا ياتي
بتفسير وهما تفسيران
متضادان لا يمكن لنا ان نجمعه ما
بحال ليس بينهما عموم وخصوص لا هما
متضادان اذا
هذا اسمه خلاف تضاد واختلاف التضاد نادر
ياتي واحد يقول نعم والاخر يقول لا واحد
يقول حلال الاخر يقول حرام ما ما يمكن
نجمع بينهما لا يمكن الجمع بين الضدين اذا
هذا الخلاف نادر جدا في القران في بين
الصحابه نادر جدا بين
الصحابه
وهو كذلك موجود عند التابعين اكثر مما هو
عند الصحابه لكن برضه قليل جدا
وهلم
جره الخلاف الكثير متى كان بعد القرون
الثلاثه المفضله لما دخلت البدع
والخزعبلات
ودخلت
الثقافات ثقافه اليونان وثقافه الفرس
وثقافه هذه الامراض التي تمس بالفطره لما
دخلت على جزيره العرب دخلت على المسلمين
صار هناك فرق
مبتدعه تبتدع في اصل الدين هناك منافقون
دخلوا في الاسلام
و
شنوا
ال الحرب على اهل الاسلام من
الداخل فظهرت الرافضه والمعتزله و هرت
الجهميه وظهرت هذه الجماعات نعم صار في
خلاف الان خلاف تضاد
وكثير لكن ليس بين اهل السنه اهل السنه
خلافهم ما زال على نمط
خلاف الصحابه
والتابعين لكن مع هذه الفرق الضاله نعم
خلاف تضاد كثير لماذا لان كل
تروم تفسير
القران على
هواها فاما الذين في قلوبهم زيغ فيتبعون
ما تشابه من ابتغاء الفتنه
وابتغاء تاويله ايش يعني تاويله يعني
ابتغاء تاويله هو ويريد ان يؤول الكتاب
على هواه يلوي
الايات
ف هذا واقع لذلك تجد علماء اهل السنه من
زمن التابعين الى يوم الناس هذا وهم
يقولون لا تاخذوا العلم ان هذا العلم دين
فانظروا عم من تاخذون دينكم العلم يؤخذ عن
اهل السنه سلاله النبوه السلاله الروحيه
السلاله
العلميه
فاذا اجينا على هذه الايه مثلا هذه الايه
الله يعلم ما تحمل كل انثى وما تغيض
الارحام وما
تزداد وكل شيء عنده بمقدار تجد الخلاف
كثير على هذه الطريقه وانا اقول هذا
الكلام ليش
لانه تفسير لو قلت لك هات يا فلان تفسير
اول تفسير يخطر ببال اكثر الناس ايش تفسير
ابن كثير اليس كذلك هذا لانه تفسير ابن
كثير
تفسير
مبارك منتشر وهذا يدل
على قبول الله سبحانه وتعالى له في الجمله
ويدل على
الاخلاص ان دل على
شيء وهو منسوج باقوال الصحابه والتابعين
واهم من ذلك منسوج
باقوال الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم ومخرج
ومحقق لكن في كثير من هذا الخلاف وابن
كثير لا ينبه على هذه الاشياء لماذا لان
القارئ المفروض يكون يفهم هذه الاشياء قبل
ان يقدم على كتاب مثل تفسير القران العظيم
لابن كثير ف الكل منا عنده هذا التفسير في
بيته فتفتح القران وتجد فلان قال هيك
مجاهد قال هيك ابن عباس قال هيك عكر ما
قال هيك وهيك يعني الانسان مرات ينزعج او
مرات ينظر الى هذه الاقوال
ويقول يعني القران مش واضح
معناه يعني القران لهالدرجه معقوله غير
واضح حتى صدر عن الصحابه كل هذه الاقوال
لا القران واضح
جدا
لكن اقوالهم على طريقه معينه اهل التفسير
يفهمون هذا
الكلام فعلى كل حال تجد مثلا في قوله
تعالى وما تغيض
الارحام وما تغيض يعني يكون في
سقط وما تزداد تزيد على تسعه اشهر الحمل
هذا وصف الان لايش للحمل مش للارحام
فجرى هنا
تسميه الحمل
بالمكان نقال تغيض
الارحام يعني الحمل مش الرحم
نفسه يجي واحد ثاني ويقول وما تغيض
الارحام يعني يكون في تشويه او يكون غير
مشوه تغيض او تزداد
بيجي واحد ثاني بقول وما تغيض الارحام وما
تزداد من ذكر او انثى وما تغيض الارحام
وما تزداد من دم او من قله دم وما تغيض
الارحام وما تزداد وهكذا هذه الاقوال كلها
بنجمع ونقول كلمه غاض يغيض معنى
النقص تزد
من الزياده الزياده واضحه اذا كل هذه
الاقوال ترجع الى المعنيين العامين هذين
فهو يقول سبحانه وتعالى وما تغيض الارحام
وما تزداد لسائل ان
يسال اليس مع التقدم العلمي هم يقولون
تقدم علمي وفي الحقيقه
علم ليس
يعني العلم الذي هو علم ظاهر الحياه
الدنيا يعلمون ظاهرا من الحياه
الدنيا فالتقدم
التكنولوجي ان صحه
العباره ققول لك في هذه الازمان ممكن
الانسان ينظر في الرحم ينظر يحط ال يحط ال
الجهاز على رحم المراه
فيرى بوضوح ما في هذا الرحم
ويصوره كيف يكون هذا من
الغيب الذي يختص الله سبحانه وتعالى به
والان جاءت هذه العلوم
نقول
قاعده نقعد بها
اولا ال
يعني ما غاب عن الناس علم الغيب ينقسم الى
قسمين
احفظوهن علم الغيب ينقسم الى
قسمين علم
غيب نسبي وعلم غيب
مطلق نسبي وايش
ومطلق علم الغيب النسبي الذي
يكون
غيبا بالنسبه للجماعه المعينه او بالنسبه
للزمن المعين
نسبي هو غيب
نسبي يعني بالنسبه الى فلان هو غيب ولغيره
ليس
غيبا او بالنسبه للمكان هذا من علم الغيب
وفي هذا المكان ليس غيبا او بالنسبه زمان
في هذا الزمان اهله يرون ان هذا من
الغيب وفي هذا
الزمان ليس من
الغيب ماشي فعندك غيب
نسبي والغيب
النسبي ما
يشترك فيه
الخلق او ما اطلعه الله سبحانه وتعالى
اطلع عليه من شاء من خلقه هذا اسمه غيب
نسبي اما الغيب
المطلق فهذا يختص الله سبحانه وتعالى
به الغيب المطلق جاء في الحديث الصحيح في
الصحيحين النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم قال
وحديث ابي هريره
قال مفاتح الغيب خم خمسه لا يعلمهن الا
الله قال صلى الله عليه وسلم لا يعلم ما
في الغد الا
الله ولا يعلم متى ينزل المطر الا
الله وما
يعلم الساعه الا الله هذه ثلاثه وما تعلم
نفس
في اي ارض تموت الا
الله الله يعلم كل نفس متى تموت وما تعلم
وما يعلم ما في الارحام الا الله هكذا في
الحديث بهذا
المعنى انظروا
الكلمه ما في الارحام
ما احنا نطلع على ماذا ذكر و انثى نطلع
عليه متى
بعد الشهر الفلاني بعد الشهر الرابع او
الخامس ايوه نطلع قبل ذلك من يعرف من يعلم
لا احد الله سبحانه وتعالى
وحده يعلم ما في
الارحام ما في الارحام ليس فقط ذكر و انثى
ليس مخصوصا بذلك هذا ظاهر العلم هذا لا
شيء الله سبحانه وتعالى يعلم ما في
الارحام جاء في
الحديث في
الصحيحين في صحيح
مسلم تفرد به مسلم من حديث ابن مسعود ان
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
قال ياتي
الملك بعد 120
يوم يؤمر بنفخ الروح في ققول اي ربي شقي
او سعيد اي ربي ما رزقه اي ربي ذكر ام
انثى اي ربي اجله اي ربي عمله
فخبره الله ويملي عليه يعني على الملك
فيكتب هذه الاشياء هذا ما في الارحام هذا
راح يكون
قبيح ام لطيف المنظر هذا راح يكون صاحب
خلق طيب طيب ولا يكون خبيث هذا يكون مسلم
ولا كافر شقي او سعيد صاحب عمل صالح ولا
عمل سيء ما رزقه ما اجله ذكر و انثى هذا
شيء من
شيء فنعم الله سبحانه وتعالى يعلم ما في
الارحام يقول تعالى وما تغ الارحام وما
تزداد وكل شيء عنده
بمقدار بمقدار يعني شيء مقدر وهذا فيه ذكر
ماذا فيه ذكر القدر انا كل شيء خلقناه
بقدر النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم قال وتؤمن
بالقدر خيره
وشره القدر خير وشر صح ولا لا لكن هذا خير
وشر ايش نسبي برضه ولا
لا يعني ما كان شرا لي قد يكون خيرا
لغيري وما كان شرا لي في الدنيا قد يكون
خيرا لي في
الاخره يقول تعالى عالم الغيب فاتبع هذه
الصفه صفه يعلم ما في الارحام
اتبعها بعالم
الغيب هذا من ابرز
صفاته سبحانه وتعالى عالم الغيب
والشهاده
الغيب هذا يسمى
مصدرا هذا مصدر تقول غاب يغيب غيبا فهو
غيب الغيب
مصدر ايش المقصود بالغيب هنا مقصود به اسم
الفاعل غائب غائب الش شيء
الغائب اطلق على اسم الفاعل خليكم معي
اطلق على اسم
الفاعل المصدر
مبالغه المبالغه ان يقول هذا غائب هذا غيب
ايش الفرق في الذهن لو قلنا مثلا هذا
عادل هذا عدل ايش الفرق
العدل اشد عدوله صح ولا لا
عدولا لاني
وصفت الفاعل
بالمصدر خليت العدل كله عند فلان هو عادل
لدرجه انه صار هو كله عدل صح ولا
لا اقول
مثلا كما قال تعالى انه عمل غير
صالح ايش يعني عمل غير صالح يعني عامل غير
صالح وفي بعض القراءات عامل غير
صالح فعلى كل حال
الغيب ما
اشتد غموضه على كل على الجميع الا الله
سبحانه وتعالى ما يختص الله به هذا اسمه
غيب واما ما يطلع عليه الانسان
وما كان غيبا نسبيا فهذا ليس من الغيب
الذي يختص الله تعالى به اذا انحلت
المشكله في
اذهاننا يقول عالم الغيب
والشهاده الشهاده ضد الغيب يعني ما غاب
وما
ظهر
الكبير سبحانه وتعالى الذي يصغر كل شيء
دونه
المتعال المتعال هنا على وزن
المتفاعل وهذا يدل على استمرار الفعل يعني
الذي يتعالى على كل شيء سبحانه
وتعالى وحذفت الياء
واثبتت كما جاء ايضا
في قولنا ولكل قوم هاد ولكل قوم هاد كل
قوم
هادي الكبير المتعال الكبير
المتعالي وجاءت القراءات السبعه في اثبات
الياء وحذف الياء بالتنوين كلاهما
بمعنى يقول سواء
منكم من اسر القول ومن جهر
به يعني الذي يسر القول اذا
القول
هل هو فقط ما يكون
باللسان الجواب لا لانه ممكن الانسان ما
يتكلم بالشيء وهذا يكون ايش يكون قول صح
ولا لا يقول به لكن في
القلب سواء منكم من اسر القول ومن جهر به
سواء يعني نفس الشيء ما في
فرق والفرق يظهر لنا لان فينا النقص واما
الله سبحانه وت تعالى فالذي يتكلم والذي
يسكت والذي يظهر والذي
يخفى والليل والنهار سواء عند الله سبحانه
وتعالى هو خالق الظلام وهو
خالق اصل غياب
الاشياء فقال تعالى سواء منكم يعني نفس
الشيء
سواء
من اسر القول ومن جهر
به ومن هو مستخف
بالليل مستخف يعني طالب التخفي في الليل
مستخف يعني يطلب ان يتخ المتخفي اللي
بحاول يخفي نفسه وسارب بالنهار سارب يعني
ظاهر
بالنهار
والارب
ماخوذ من فعل
سرب
او من الاسم السرب السرب اللي هو الطريق
هذا اسمه
سرب ويقال فلان سارب يعني يمشي على
الطريق سارب بالنهار يعني شاق طريقه في ه
الدنيا بالنهار كلها نفس الشيء
بوضوح والليل والنهار هنا مثل اليس
كذلك يقول مستخف بالليل ممكن يكون مستخف
بالنهار وسارب بالنهار ممكن يكون سارب
بالليل صح ولا لا لكن
المقصود ان الذي في غايه
الخفاء والذي في غايه الوضوح هذه سواء عند
الله لا اله الا الله يقول تعالى ومن هو
مستخف بالليل وسارب من بالنهار له معقبات
ونكمل ذلك غدا ان شاء الله تعالى
اعلم
yesterday the 8 n
andes chapter
قران سه الر chapter
thund الله سبحانه
وتعالى ‏say
translates الله knows every female
cares and the
woms do not decrease nor
increase except that allah knows it he
knows every female cares and he knows
every fem wom increases or
decreases and everything
الله سبحانه
وتالى
perly meed is
perfect is given a
per الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه وتالى
tells
‏regarding female
cares every
femes this is the proper translation the
proper transl is not allah knows what
every fem cares allah
knows about what every fem cares from
the considered
toing from the moment
‏and if we understand this ver in this
way we
understand that there is
no there is no
issue with modern soed modern technology
that now can if the female ising a male
female the
الله سبحانه
وتالى as as
any الله سبحانه
وتعالى الله
وسل عبد الله
بنعود صلى الله عليه
وسلم0 days sends ang
that
in and the
angel
الله
‏the angel asks and
says shall it be male or
female what length of life what shall be
susten shall be good or
bad wicked or
rous of the people of paradise or of the
people of hell and allah will tell the
angel and the angel will write down then
‏so we see not
isale and we see how our so modern
technology is compared to these ancient
words speaking الله سبحانه
وتالى speaking الله سبحانه وتال
destion
‏with
allah is given an allotment every is
given me measure everything is perfectly
measured out
perfect to us it seems things are
close and things are far but to allah
they are exactly exactly as they are
supposed to
be reas صل الله عليه وسلم ابن
عس يا غلام اني اعلمك
كلمات and one things
his ع was said him وعلم ان ما اخطاك لم
يكن ليصيبك وان ما اصابك لم يكن
ليخطئك
never never any
‏h no chance and
never الله سبحانه
وتعالى
ex والشهاده الكبير
المتعال
الله
‏that
isen and that clear
toone he is the great and he is the one
who is ever
high
else سبحانه
وتعالى
الله
are ‏and keep their words to
themselves and those who
outwardly announce their
words it is the same and equal to allah
those among you who are hiding their
actions in the depth of night and those
who are clearly walking in the he of
day these things are equal to allah we
perce that which is
‏more
unle الله سبحانه
وتعالى الله سبحانه
وتعالى
as things are
‏some clear more
clear not clear all these
are الله سبحانه
وتعالى after describing himself now
describing the stat of the human being
of human being in ver
number ان شاء الله اعلم الله وسلم على
نبينا
[Silence]
محمد
ان